good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
1357 object class
safe special containment procedures the
perimeter of SCP 1357 is to be monitored
by Foundation Personnel at all times
with a minimum of two security Personnel
posted at every entrance and exit of the
park any persons approaching SCP 1357
are to be detained by Foundation
personnel and administered Class B
amnestics if the persons are carrying
instances of SCP 1357 B the instances
are to be confiscated and filed in the
records room of site 45 cabinet 74 or
possible future testing on the 13th of
every month Foundation agents are to
identify the persons receiving the new
instances of SCP 1357 B recover the
instances and administer class b
amnestics to the persons involved due to
these specific Personnel required to
activate the anomalous properties of SCP
1357 d-class testing of this anomaly is
effectively impossible testing of this
object may be accomplished by groups of
foundation Personnel able to provide the
required subjects necessary to manifest
SCP 1357 a any persons involved in
testing that are not directly involved
in Foundation matters must be
administered Class A amnestics after
testing and monitored for 2 months for
signs of residual memories any subjects
showing residual memories are to be
readministered class am amnestics and
monitored for another 2 months due to
these constraints all testing must be
kept to a minimum and approved by no
less than three level four and 5 level
three
personnel description SCP 1357 is a
theme park located in Poland with an
area of approximately 4 km squared there
are four ticket booths that allow
entrance into the park located at the
northern eastern southern and western
sides of the area SCP 1357 houses
various attractions normally found at
theme parks such as amusement rides
bumper cars and and assorted booths and
stores no items Commodities or snacks
require currency of any kind to operate
or purchase the types of rides and
attractions seem to be influenced by the
preferences of the youngest subject in
the group activating SCP 1357 anomalous
effects rides found in non-anomalous
theme parks have been observed as well
as attractions such as Sapient food
stuffs and animals temporal
displacements and extradimensional
portals SCP 1357 anomalous properties
are activated when a specific group of
people enter the park the requirements
of the group are as follows at least two
subjects that are involved in a romantic
relationship with each other at least
one subject under the age of 18 that
identifies the aforementioned subjects
as Guardians and each subject must carry
an instance of SCP 1357 B when these
requirements are met a group of human
individuals designated as scp3 1 57a
manifest throughout the anomalous area
SCP 1357 a manifestations vary in age
ethnicity sex and gender all instances
are always uniformly costumed the
costumes are typically based on
characters from various media notable
characters that instances of SCP 1357 a
have shown costumed as include Winnie
the Poo Barney the dinosaur and Batman
the appearance of SCP 1357 a appears to
be strongly influenced by the personal
experiences of the youngest subject in
the group The instances of SCP 1357 a
appear within the park as both customers
and employees and are noted to be
exceptionally amiable SCP 1357 B are
tickets that read Playland admits one
person per ticket have a magical family
experience in the native language of the
recipients they are delivered to
instances of SCP 1350 7B have been found
to be mailed to assorted families around
the area along with directions to the
park and a short pamphlet describing SCP
1357 see adendum 1357 gamma for a
bridged transcription of the pamphlet
instances of SCP 1357 B are consistently
delivered on the 13th day of every month
the foundation has not yet discovered
the source of the tickets nor has it
found a pattern regarding the recipients
of SCP 1357 B families have reportedly
received anywhere from 3 to six
instances of SCP 1357 B at once if a
ticket is not redeemed for entrance into
the park before the 13th day of the
following month the tickets will
disappear SCP 13 57b will allow entrance
into the park by any individual
regardless whether they were the
intended recipient or not any personel
that are not carrying SCP 1357 B that
attempt to enter the park will be denied
accessed by several instances of SCP
1357 a SCP 1357 was discovered when the
foundation was alerted to reports of a
constantly changing alien amusement park
from the town of Poland the claims were
investigated and traced back to SCP
1357 which was active at the time of
Discovery all citizens of the Town were
questioned and administered Class B
amnestics addendum 135 7
gamma congratulations your family has
been selected to participate in some
good old family fun at play parents
bring your kids and kids bring your
parents take some time off of working
and take some time for playing we have
everything you want from roller coasters
to parades to fireworks and anything
else you can imagine as long as you
remember to ask nicely if you want to
talk to a representative call us at or
visit us online
[Applause]
at.com Foundation calls to this number
have revealed no new information other
than typical hours of service of the
park interview log 1357 Lambda 1 on
0408 2005 agent Fredericks and his
immediate family were equipped with
audio recording devices that constantly
transmitted to Foundation console
they entered SCP 1357 using three
confiscated instances of SCP 1357 B
Frederic attempted to interview an
instance of SCP 1357
a interviewed SCP 1357 a 4878 which was
dressed similar to Steve from the
Children's Program Blues Clues
interviewer agent Frederick forward
agent Fredericks had isolated a single
SCP 1357 a subject out of the population
wandering around the park for the
purpose of this interview begin
log can you tell me about this place
sure Playland is a place for all your
family fun needs we cater specifically
to your family's needs each time and do
our best to make sure you're satisfied
who made you Mr Frederick that's
certainly not important no members of
the Frederick's family had previously
revealed their last name to any instance
of SCP 1357 a it is important please
just answer my questions not right now
sweetie I'm trying to work work why Mr
Fredericks there's no need to worry
about anything so silly as work just
have fun look your daughter wants you to
play Hal Le I'll be there in a minute I
promise no I'm not being mean to Steve
go over with Mom
okay I'm afraid that I must work right
now you're exactly why I have my job I'm
sorry but if you can't relax I'm afraid
you're going to ruin the fund for
everything else if you don't stop please
just answer the
questions now how long has this park
been open I'm terribly sorry to do this
but you seem to be upsetting your
daughter and log closing statement agent
Frederick's was forcibly removed from
SCP
1357 by three instances of SCP 1357 7A
agent Frederick's wife attempted to exit
the park despite great protest from
their daughter as Adelaide Frederick's
attempted to leave the park several
instances of SCP 1357 a separated the
subjects preventing Mrs Frederick from
re-entering the park and leading their
daughter by hand back into the park one
of the individuals was noted as saying
don't worry sweetie you don't have to
leave if you don't want to they'll be
back for you later when you're ready
after the events of interview log 1357
Lambda 1 mobile task force Delta 2 AKA
Rescue Rangers was dispatched in an
attempt to recover Haley Fredericks from
SCP
1357 despite Superior Firepower and
training mobile task force Delta 2 was
outnumbered and overwhelmed by SCP 1357
a instances and was unable to recover
the subject further recovery attempts
are currently
pending interview log 1357 Lambda 2
Haley Frederick's audio recording device
continued to transmit signals after the
events of interview log 1357 Lambda 1
the following are excerpts of audio
received all voices not positively
identified as belonging to Haley
Fredericks are presumed to belong to
various instances of SCP 1357
a hey why are you a girl Steve why all
the boys stes are busy getting the park
ready for
you this is so so so much fun I never
ever ever want to leave I love you Mr
Steve I love you too Haley I'm so glad
you came to join
us guess what's here Haley what is it
what is it here's the mail it's just a
snail it makes me want to wag my tail
when it comes I want to whale mail no
the song goes
uh the song says it never fails not it's
just a
snail silly me I forgot anyways here are
your letters you got one from your mom
and your dad yay thank
you um Mr Steve I can't read can you
tell me what this says of course honey
dear Haley we hope you're having a lot
of fun we would love to come visit but
we have so much work and we're tired
just send us a letter when you want to
come home and we'll be there right away
P.S daddy says brush your
teeth agent Fredericks reported that
neither he nor his wife had written
letters to their daughter during this
time and here's the biggest bedroom we
have you get to sleep here Haley I hope
you like it we made that big thinking
chair just for you we made sure it was
big enough and snuggly enough to sleep
on every night oh I love it thank you Mr
Stevie
why aren my mommy and daddy coming yet I
thought I wrote that letter so good oh
haly maybe they're just busy I'm sure
that they'll be here as soon as they
read that
letter Mr Steve when is my mommy and
daddy coming back what's the matter
honey are you not having fun anymore oh
I am I just want to know when I have to
go home oh Haley you're always welcome
here yay is so happy you're here Mr
Steve my legs hurt my legs hurt I've
been winning forever are you sure the
letter said they were cing
today hm let me check again we've got
your wonderful letter on the day off
coming on Saturday front entrance yep
that's what the letter says H can we go
back inside I want a slushie of course
Haley and while while we're there we can
write you another letter to ask them why
they didn't come when you asked them
to did we say yesterday sorry sweetie we
forgot we were real busy doing our
grownup things and didn't remember to
pick you up we're real sorry I think we
have another day off next month so we
can pick you up then love daddy and
mommy Steve do mommies and daddies stop
loving their babies h sometimes I think
why do you ask I think my mommy and
daddy's to loving me oh oh oh dear
friend don't be upset we are here to
love you even if your mean old parents
won't forever forever promise promise
we'll always be here for you even if
they
aren't Miss Steve I want my mommy and
daddy Haley stop thinking such silly
thoughts about those mean people here
have some more funnel cake then we can
ride on the carousel again no no no no I
want my mommy and
daddy oh dare you they're no fun I'm
here for you now we are your family come
on let's play I don't want to play no
more Miss Steve sure you do silly come
on there's a brand new playground that's
all for
you can you take me to them why aren't
you having fun anymore I miss my mommy
and daddy a whole whole lot but we are
your family nuh-uh you're my friends I
want my family so you don't love us
anymore of course I do but I love my
family even
more well it always happens eventually
come on let's get you to your
family approximately 5 minutes of
footsteps Dave
Steve I think we're lost I know Deary I
know what's that thing it looks scary
you said you wanted your family didn't
you Haley well come on this will take
you right to them promise of course
Haley I would never lie to you
well okay there is a sound of hissing as
well as ass sorted beeps and worrying
see you soon
sister note
at this point the audio transmission
device ceased
functioning incident report 1357 Zeta
agent Frederick's returned to SCP 1357
on authorized the day following the
previously described events and
proceeded to kill approximately 30
instances of SCP 1357 a while shouting
obscenities Fredericks ceased firing
upon viewing a subject that appeared to
be Haley Fredericks who approached the
front entrance of SCP 1357 the subject
hugged agent Frederick's and said I told
you I don't want to leave yet
subsequently two instances of SCP 1357 a
approached the agent and rendered him
unconscious via blows to the Head agent
Frederick had been issued a warning for
unprofessional behavior and damaging the
anomaly incident report 1357 Ada agent
Frederick was allowed to oversee testing
of SCP 1357
on 1610 2005 during experimentation
agent Fredericks used a spare instance
of SCP 1357 B and entered the area
independent of the test subjects
Frederick sought out the subject
resembling Haley Frederick's and
reportedly attempted to converse with it
the subject did not respond and
Frederick ceased attempts at
communication after approximately 15
minutes then left the
park site director's note as of 1610
2005 agent Frederick is required to
attend a minimum of eight counseling
sessions with the on-site psychologist
Dr Yates furthermore Frederick has been
hereby reassigned to
SCP and is forbidden from working with
SCP
1357 site direct
langle audio log 1357 s the following
log was transcribed from an intercepted
telephone call to SCP 1357 using the
number from the pamphlet provided with
every delivery of SCP 1357 B one of the
voices has been positively identified as
belonging to Haley Frederic playing log
now hello you've reached Playland the
perfect place for family fun how may I
help you I want my daughter back I'm
sorry sir but I'm afraid your daughter
just wanted to stay with us you can
always visit though just let us know and
we'll send you two complimentary tickets
I think she wants to stay
though and
lo this concludes today's lecture thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you're all dismissed
[Music]
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to
zargaran
BP o crop guy the Morgan JMS Saba Irish
westwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazaon worthy fire Dr Wolf
13 cubster Dean
Denis that loser casadia cams
braded peit James Wright Rowan
O'Brien
kegn
Grier extra moments
123 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
[Music]
you